I want to see if Nikola is actually evil
or became corrupted by moog's
interference what happened to his great
Rune if he claimed one personally I
think nikola's story is going to be
exactly like the story of Griffith from
berserk which is one of the few anime
that I actually like nothing against
anime it's just not my thing for the
most part but based on everything that
we can infer from the game mikola was
well loved by almost everybody and was
constantly trying to find a cure for the
burdens that he and his family were
afflicted by the greatest example of
this is obviously his twin sister
Melania and her Scarlet rot with his
creation of analoid gold which would
hold back the spread of the rot that was
quite literally causing Melania to lose
most of her limbs there could be many
reasons why mikola created the halog
tree but my theory ultimately lands on
mikola actually failing to help himself
and his sister in the end and in a
last-ditch effort gave himself to Moog
to hopefully grow himself into more than
just a child